hello everyone
um you may have noticed i live in
england and it's the middle of winter
it's freezing
so i'm going to warm myself up today
with a load of cups of tea delicious
um that's not true what i'm doing is you
may have noticed all the descriptions of
the videos i always write
filmed at you know a thousand fps or
something and the fps stands for frames
per second
basically on a high speed camera the
higher the frame rate
the slower the motion is it's how many
pictures it's taking
in one second basically so i'm gonna
smash these mugs
at five hundred thousand two thousand
five hundred and five thousand frames a
second they're all pretty common frame
rates to my channel if you've seen
previous videos
but there's one frame rate i'm going to
do today that i've never done before on
the channel
10 000 frames a second it has to be a
reduced resolution but we'll see how it
turns out i'm pretty sure it's going to
be
horribly slow but we'll see
all right this is where we do quite a
lot of our filming
but as you can see it's winter so the
sun is so low
even on a sunny day the sun never
actually touches the ground here so i'm
gonna have to do this
somewhere else
now the reason i have to do this in the
sunlight is because as you'll notice
as the frame rate goes up the light goes
down
gets darker and darker as you shoot
faster
and at 10 000 frames
it's pretty freaking dark
right
all right well now we have a good speed
comparison thanks to these
poor innocent mugs um before i turn this
off i'm going to say
go and watch sherlock holmes the second
movie a game of shadows
because i worked on it and there's a ton
of slow motion in it
shot with this exact camera that i use
for the slow-mo guys
so watch the movie let me know what you
think of the slow-mo
i honestly think it's probably one of
the most mental action scenes
i've ever seen so let me know what you
think see you later
so
you